[Musique]
le riz sauvage est un graminées
indigènes en amérique du nord
ces grandes tiges que l'on appelle aussi
folle avoine pousse dans les grandes
étendues d'eau peu profonde
j'aime beaucoup le riz sauvage parce que
c'est un grain qui nourrit très très
bien on peut je suis à manger comme ça
sans viande
mais le riz sauvage c'est exemplaire de
nos traditions autochtones soient neige
bertrand de la nation à coude et neko et
des territoires du nord ouest veut faire
vivre la tradition du riz sauvage par
l'entremise de son service de traiteur
autochtone et beaucoup de nous et qui
viennent dinan il ya les innu de
schefferville etc
il ya les attikameks c'est comme un
meeting pâtissière montréal et mon
travail en tant que tel de traiteur ça
vient du fait que notre communauté ici à
montréal en a besoin on a pas de
restaurants autochtone
moi je fais plus à manger fusion je
prends les éléments autochtone puis je
fais beaucoup à manger
le mcs ma nation manger dans les temps
de mes ancêtres
c'est beaucoup pour montrer respect à
mes ancêtres du doigt ce qu'est juillet
puis respect à mon corps aussi
les premières nations récolte le riz
sauvage depuis toujours de manière
traditionnelle à bord d'un canot en
battant les tiges au dessus de
l'embarcation
certaines entreprises de l'ontario du
manitoba et de la saskatchewan ont
développé des techniques de récolte
permettant de le commercialiser et de
leur rendre plus facilement disponibles
les américains cultive maintenant ce riz
il n'a plus rien sauvage le riz sauvage
contient 4 % de protéines donc plus que
le riz blanc et le riz agréé entier il
contient également des fibres et c'est
une excellente source de minéraux
c'est aussi une cyrielle naturellement
dépourvu du gluten c'est très très
nutritif
je n'ai pas l'équivalent d'un steak mais
moi des fois je me fais juste mangé la
salade comme le cha placer d'avoir trois
cas tellement avec pour ses cuissons
après avoir rincé laurie on recommande
de le faire bouillir pendant 45 à 50
minutes dans une grande quantité d'eau
puis de les goûter soit neige propose
plutôt de le faire tremper pendant douze
à vingt-quatre heures james reese
labrador kagel mais avec l'eau chaude
basse dans un bassin ou sinon je mets
des poches de thé le riz sauvage prend
le goût du thé juste le rincer les
tremper une vie d'échangé l'eau un bon
12 heures minimum qui change beaucoup y
allure 4 quand y tremper ou qu est
regardée fleuri comme un cas moi je le
fais cuire jeu sale trempé comme ça il
resterait toujours al dante et il va
jamais comme trop cuire
si on le fait trop cuire il craint goût
pas te un peu lumineuse
ça fait envie garder le petit crunch et
son succès
[Applaudissements]
une fois cuit elle nous propose deux
façons de le servir
inspiré des recettes traditionnelles
autochtones le prêt pass du par simple
peu de sel car votre console et des
oignons revenu puis un peu des fois un
peu d'huile puis dîner
mais pour que le gouffre sorte de dans
le riz sauvage
mon secret c'est que je rajoute un peu
de sirop d'érable comme ça ça n'enlève
le petit goût amer de un peu le goût de
faire du riz sauvage
c'est comme ça que les élus ni l'autre 7
c'est un secret de famille est une
famille crie qui me le montrer je prends
le riz sauvage mélange avec un peu de
crème ce un petit peu maillot ou goût
puis les pacanes ddc liquide puis des
canneberges sa fête à la fraîche mais ça
ça devient presque un repas complet
l'heure exacte
c'est tellement protéines dans la vie
savadori sauvage mais sinon si j'en
prenne plus petite quantité avec quoi je
pourrais accompagner
malade à mon visage avec des volailles
comme du canard de l'oie
tu as l'air tellement bon bon appétit
merci beaucoup
[Musique]